Alright, so, I'm going to go to set times, to try and test this out.
>> Before we go to test it out, don't forget to click
Activate. I always forget to do that, especially on work flows and approvals.
>> After activating, you cannot add or remove that's fine. Okay, we
are activated. Set times. So should I create a new set time?
>> So you could create a new set time, or,
we could just use one of the ones we already created.
>> Okay. Send it for approval?
>> Sounds good.
Alright, so there we see it. So in the
Approval History, we saw when you submitted it for approval,
>> Okay.
>> Who its assigned to. And then they can come here and
approve, reject or possibly reassign it to someone else to approve it.
>> And this is just visible to me because
I happen to be, the approval, the approver as well?
>> So depending on your security settings.
>> huh.
>> You might not be able to see it, but honestly, if you can see this record,
anyone should be able to see where this is at in the Approval Flow.
>> Okay. Gotcha. Okay so now, I should have
gotten a notification, and now I can approve it, right?
>> Right. So first, look at the status.
>> In Review.
>> It moved into Review.
>> Okay. That's pretty cool.
>> So sweet.
>> So now, should I go to Home?
>> Well, you can improve it right from here.
>> Oh, right. Here?
>> Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> So you can leave some comments with it. Do you approve the set time?
>> I approve.
>> So you can see the Record's still locked. Now
that it's confirmed, you can unlock it whenever you want.
>> Very cool. Alright. I don't want to unlock it.
>> All right.
>> I want it to be a secret.
>> Lock it up.
>> Okay.